netflix is tanking they're raising
prices they're cutting content and
they're doing the unthinkable not
letting you share your password but
today i have the solution today i am
gonna single-handedly save netflix
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that puts the eye in binge if
you haven't seen it in the news by now
netflix is in trouble the beloved video
rental service has actually lost
subscribers for the first time ever in
its history and as a result its stock
price has plummeted down into the pooper
setting it to the lowest it's been in
nearly five years it is a bloodbath now
as the film theory guy i've spent a lot
of time on netflix binging their shows i
went frame by frame through squid game i
love me some stranger things i aspire to
be a judge unnailed it and i strongly
consider inside job to be the new rick
and morty heck i even watched and
re-watched sabrina the teenage witch to
search for signs of mephisto it's not
mephisto tldr i don't want netflix to go
away but things aren't looking too good
the loyalist of film theorists watching
right now might remember an episode i
did two years ago shortly after the
launch of disney plus all about which
streaming services i predicted would
live which would die and which would
tell their story as a six-hour
multi-part documentary in it i
specifically said this about netflix's
chances of winning the streaming wars
the tldr here is that this date night
juggernaut ain't going nowhere at least
until it starts running out of money but
it spends the vast majority of its
revenue on new programming meaning that
it has no buffer to survive a few lean
years now netflix has to perform or die
it has to create its own shows that are
big hits or else it's gonna fall apart
when it starts falling apart it falls
apart in a hurry so netflix's chances of
being the winner here are slim lo and
behold that's exactly what we see
happening right now the company is
crumbling under the increased pressure
from other streaming services and is now
desperately searching for solutions i
mean i'm not gonna say i called it but
you know i'm just might just put a plus
one over in this column anyway i want to
do my best to help out so listen up here
um
uh who do i talk to for this one hold on
i got it i got it it's in my papers ceo
of netflix read hastings seamless i
think i have the solutions to your
problem today matpat is here to give you
15 minutes of free consulting we are
gonna single-handedly save netflix i
just hope that you listen a little bit
better than some other people i've tried
to help in the past uh heck star wars
just saying they ignored me and uh look
how well it turned out for them first
let me catch you up netflix was founded
way back in 1997 as the story goes
founder reed hastings got the idea after
receiving a 40 fine at blockbuster for
losing the movie apollo 13. now
obviously that's the fun version of the
story that they like to tell the press
in reality it was just business people
trying to figure out how to make money
by creating the next amazon if amazon is
a store shipping goods directly to your
house then what else could be delivered
directly to your doorstep movies and
thus the concept was born the idea was
to create a video rental service with no
late fees that would ship the still
newish format of dvds through the mail
to you rather than relying on brick and
mortar stores this was fairly successful
but things took a massive turn in 2007
when netflix began offering the option
to stream some of their movies directly
through the internet the standard 599 a
month disc plan bought subscribers a
whopping six hours of streaming per
month ironically wouldn't be enough time
to actually get through an entire season
of a show nowadays also as someone who
has subscribed through that era the
selection was slim usually just a lousy
sequel to a movie while the original
remained male only but you know what
that was all it took the speed and
convenience of streaming became the
preferred way to watch sure quality
might have been lower when streaming but
sometimes you just need that immediate
satisfaction of pumping bridger tin into
your brain by 2011 netflix announced
production of its first original series
house of cards which had a budget of 100
million dollars fast forward to today
when netflix is launching a new original
series practically every day in a single
episode of stranger things cost some 30
million dollars to make times have
certainly changed the landscape though
has also changed it took him a few years
to take streaming seriously but now
entertainment behemoths like disney and
hbo have entered the fray with more
production experience stronger ips and
deeper libraries which have allowed them
to quickly take a bite out of netflix's
subscriber numbers and this has resulted
in netflix starting to panic early in
2022 netflix made a series of very
controversial statements first off the
price was gonna go up to a lot of people
this seemed unfair because it wasn't
like netflix was suddenly offering more
than before in fact quite contrary a few
weeks later netflix said that it would
be pulling back on its original content
all of this then culminated in what's
probably become netflix's most infamous
announcement a promise to crack down on
password sharing now uh if you'll excuse
me i have to make some very awkward
phone calls to my mom and my aunt and my
other aunt and my aunt's son-in-law to
show you just how bad things are for
them right now reed hastings said the
company was considering adding a
subscription tier that was cheaper but
ad supported this is a huge deal since
netflix's whole thing has been not
needing ads in fact my boy reed over
here would brag about how they were a
better service because they didn't need
ads now when it comes to solutions some
are easier than others for instance
solving the password crackdown is easy
don't just don't do it for almost 15
years now people have been freely
sharing their netflix passwords cracking
down now is not the thing that's gonna
save you password sharing isn't a bug
for netflix it's a feature lots of
people think that ten dollars a month is
too much for standard definition quality
considering how much they use netflix
but they don't mind chipping in with a
group of their friends heck with a group
of three people everyone can pay four
dollars a month and you get high
definition content if netflix plans to
keep increasing its prices regardless of
the reason password sharing is the thing
that's going to protect them from any
negative backlash plus changing your
netflix password on an x is a
surprisingly satisfying power move just
saying while it might seem like an
attractive way to quickly boost the
numbers back up it's a short-term gain
at best as it gets people to question
whether they really need this service at
all and it leaves a pretty negative
taste in people's mouths for anyone who
decides to stick around it's a move that
looks and feels desperate but let's
actually talk about those price
increases shall we netflix could have
blamed the price increase on the
worldwide inflation but instead they
went and said this quote we're updating
our prices so that we can continue to
offer a wide variety of quality
entertainment options so in netflix's
own words it's the content that's
killing them except that they also
announced that they're cutting back on
original content this implies that
original content is becoming far more
expensive to make and yeah that actually
tracks amazon prime just created the
most expensive show in tv history the
lord of the rings the rings of power
which cost an astounding
465 million dollars to make that is over
100 million more than the budget of
avengers endgame disney plus spent a
reported 225 million on one division and
as i mentioned the final season of
stranger things is coming in at roughly
270 million but the problem isn't the
cost it's what you're doing with the
shows once you've spent all that money
making them ever wonder why i became the
analytics guy over here on youtube not
only was it because i was a math nerd
and i just like numbers but it was also
cause these episodes took so darn long
to make a hundred hours all by myself
with a full-time job to boot i needed to
make sure that each episode i managed to
finish got as many views as possible and
could last until my next upload and the
analytics helped me figure out how to
ring every last view out of each video
that i produce and netflix you're sloppy
about this you see there are three main
types of promotional media owned media
paid media and earned media owned media
is the promotion that you get from the
things that you own your youtube channel
your website whatever in the case of
netflix that big rotating banner when
you first log in that's probably the
best owned media that they have because
everyone who logs in sees it paid media
is the extra promotion that you get from
paying people tv commercials ads
influencer campaigns let's be honest
netflix has been mismanaging both of
these forms of media for a while now did
anyone actually see the cuphead show
when it launched because i was excited
about it but i actively had to dig in
order to find it on netflix same thing
with arcane which netflix says that i
have a 97 match for my friend colleen
miranda sings literally had a show on
netflix haters back off and i had to
double check the day that it launched
because i didn't see any promotion for
it those are all failures of owned and
paid media and honestly it makes sense
when you're launching a new series
almost every day you only have so much
promotional budget to go around so much
screen real estate to dedicate to a
thumbnail but that's your problem you're
paying for the content but you're not
promoting it in a way that guarantees
that it gets seen by the people who want
to see it it's like if mr beast spent
millions of dollars on his squid game
video and then made a title and
thumbnail that looked like this if you
can't commit to seeing a show through to
its launch and i mean really giving it
your all then you're just throwing your
money away save that show for later sure
shows like the mandalorian are riding on
the backs of giants but with nearly 222
million subscribers to their service
netflix can also be a king maker here
they can create a hit show out of
nothing just by putting something front
and center and believing in it enough to
let it sit there and be promoted but you
have to commit to doing that and right
now you can't cause you just have too
much stuff coming out you have to be
pickier about what you greenlight which
leads us to the big x factor here that
netflix is missing it's the third type
of media earn media that's the stuff
that you get for free from people just
being inspired to talk about and share
what you've done now netflix look at
where your hundreds of millions of
dollars are going for lord of the rings
and wand division that money is going
directly into merchandisable ip shows
that can show up as t-shirts and
halloween costumes and action figures on
store shelves and i'll share stranger
things has some of that congratulations
you too can now dress like a normal kid
for halloween it's one of the few big
hits on netflix actually able to do it
take a look at netflix's biggest stars
squid game sure sell some pink jumpsuits
and playstation masks over at the local
spencer's gifts beyond that though
remember bird box huge streaming numbers
but you can't sell an action figure of a
monster that's invisible the documentary
series tiger king sure action figures
exist but are you really gonna want them
and all of their biggest shows are like
this the queen's gambit bridgerton 13
reasons why the ip that they're paying
to create is watchable yeah but that's
it they don't have legs beyond the
screen because shows like ozark and the
crown aren't really built for anything
beyond the screen those aren't fandoms
that are just gonna go out and buy a
jason bateman plushie but you know what
is the mandalorian you know what looks
good on a poster grogu heck baby yoda is
probably the single most important
marketing tool that disney ever created
without him disney plus would be looking
very different these days when i say
that netflix needs things that can live
on store shelves it's not about the
money that you make selling a 13 reasons
why tape player it's about the show
feeling important and staying top of
mind baby yoda has earned so much media
since he was first introduced as people
draw him ship him meme him buy plushies
and t-shirts of him you cannot escape
grogu to the point where even people who
weren't interested just had to get
disney plus in order to check out the
show and see what all the hype was about
netflix shows don't have that baked into
their formulas they aren't choosing
shows that can develop fandoms and when
they do they aren't doing enough to help
cultivate those fandoms trusting an
algorithm to create a show that is a
witty offbeat dark comedy like russian
dial might get you a good show sure but
it's not getting you a fandom that
requires a human touch but that's all
just talking about show selection and
promotion there's one last way that
netflix is shooting themselves in the
foot and holding back its earned media
potential release schedule disney plus
released one wandavision's nine episodes
between january and march of 2021.
amazon plans to air one of eight
episodes of their lord of the rings show
per week starting in september and
ending in november netflix has
traditionally dropped a full season of
their shows all in one day in their
current nosedive panic they're actually
going to split the season of stranger
things they're releasing half of the new
season later this month and the other
half at the top of july but regardless
of whether we're talking about one
massive dump or a split dump i think
it's costing them i know i know you love
binging shows but what if i told you
that you weren't actually liking the
experience more a study done on
university of melbourne students looked
at the impact of watching shows an
episode a week an episode a day or
binged all at once they found that when
binging you may have a better
recollection of individual facts and
details linking the episodes but your
overall enjoyment of those episodes
decreases here's the graph of enjoyment
levels once a day is at the top there
the highest levels of enjoyment the blue
line on the bottom represents the group
that binge watched the show clearly
binge watching is lowering your overall
enjoyment one episode a week right there
in the middle a little bit more standard
and it's still significantly more
enjoyable but why would that be well for
one thing it makes the content feel less
disposable binging is just that it feels
like junk food you consume it fast and
then you move on there's no chance to
savor something compare that to having
to wait a week between uploads one
professor associated with the study
theorized that there's something of a
christmas morning effect when you have
to wait to open your presents if you're
just watching shows in an endless loop
you only activate certain reward centers
in your brain watching a show releases
opiates and cannabinoids that make your
brain feel good and tell you to do it
again but opiates and cannabinoids don't
represent the entirety of positive
hormones in your brain anticipatory
chemicals such as dopamine get you
excited for things to come without those
reactions the binge watchers miss out on
a large portion of the viewing
experience they don't get time to
consider the possible twists the
lingering mysteries fantasize about
possible endings and while the study
doesn't consider this the bingers in a
real world scenario would be missing out
on all the social interactions with
their friends you're cutting out your
earned media potential at the knees i
mean just look at this channel film
theory alone was able to put out three
different wand vision theories during
its run as each week offered a chance to
speculate but stranger things when
everything is out there all at once
ready to consume the best i can do is
maybe guess about the next season the
end result is that netflix gets short
spikes of interest but then a quick loss
of interest spreading out the release
schedule is practically free marketing
for any decent show it's also going to
lower the cost of making new productions
because suddenly you need fewer of them
netflix was somewhat infamous for
greenlighting lots and lots of shows to
fill its schedule i don't know five of
my friends got netflix knowing that its
fans are binging through its content
netflix felt a pressure to deliver new
content on a constant basis after all
squid game only kept me watching netflix
for about nine hours what am i gonna do
with the other 721 hours in a month
think critically about my life choices
i'd rather die if they spread squid game
out over three months though i could
fill my time between episodes theorizing
about what happens next who the old guy
really is who was behind it all that
would mean that netflix suddenly doesn't
need to bring out as much content to
keep people hooked on their platform
each customer only needs to gravitate to
one show every three months and that is
a huge difference a slower release
schedule allows netflix more time to
focus on individual projects freeing up
both budget and promotional space to
create fewer but better shows and then
using all of your powers to promote them
and ensure that they're winners rather
than being shuffled off the big front
page banner the next day when yet
another season of the circle launches
the time between episodes would allow
theorists and other fans to engage with
the content create free advertisement
enhance the experience for the fans and
all of it improves user experience as
that study showed to me it seems like an
obvious choice it's an easy decision
that shouldn't take an enormous amount
of time and resources to implement but
could save the company untold millions
while also making their customers
happier then hopefully netflix won't be
losing their users anymore and won't
have to worry about silly things like
cracking down on password sharing like i
said i really don't want to have that
talk with my nana but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut
[Music]
you